[Music]
so as a guy that's on cable television
but you obviously intimately get
internet culture what do you make of
television in general right now like not
not only on the sports side well let's
talk about a sports side first like you
know there's huge problems at ESPN
they're there I mean they just fired
what like 500 people a ton of on-air
people guys that were legends there for
20 35 100 people 100 on air people right
I think maybe yeah previously the year
before they dumped three four hundred
people but here recently it's been about
a hundred but yeah so they're having
major problems people are cutting the
cord and we know all that stuff you're
on Fox Sports about different situation
over there but how does that feel for
you to be in a in a industry that is
just going under so much change and yet
it times you understand the other
culture that's killing it I think that
and I've written this in the Wall Street
Journal that ESPN and other media
outlets have been so consumed with
politics that they forgot how to do
business I agree and so and they've been
so focused on the political construct
rather than innovation and how do we
keep our business healthy and I feel
horrible for the people that are paying
the price for this mistake because if a
business because the Espeon to business
it's not a political machine and the
first thing a business has to do is take
care of its employees and make sure they
have a place to work and and they have
abandoned that by thinking that
progressive ideology is a sound business
move and it's just a political agenda
it's not a business move yeah and if
anything it might be a business move
that's the opposite of what their
audience wants the reverse business move
actually I think without question
because again remove politics from it
Sports is a conservative culture it's a
coaches come in from Little League on
any problem we
got gets solved in this locker oh no
excuses I don't care what outsiders are
doing the referee makes a bad call we
move on yeah we control our destiny we
don't hear what color you are with your
sexuality data can you play yes it's a
meritocracy yeah and when you start
injecting all of these far left
progressive conversations on to a group
of people of our home and this is
inconsistent with what I've been taught
in sports this isn't what I expected and
so whether people like it or not it's
easier more appropriate and better
business to talk sports from a
conservative perspective than it is from
a progressive perspective it's just
that's just factual you know it's so
funny to me because when I was in
college I really wanted to be a sports
center anchor that's what I want to be
and I went to college in the in the mid
90s when it was to me the heyday of
sports center when Kilbourne was earlier
who was the first one to me that made it
funny to which I thought was also and he
was the heyday of Dan Patrick and
Oberman who have both gone very
political in different directions these
days
so it's funny for me to be sitting
across from someone that's that's in
that world that so acknowledges how
haywire it's gotten because Sports
Center used to be fun and funny and now
when I click on their so it's always
political and that has nothing to do
with why you watch sports is the escape
not not the vehicle for more it is
nonsense and again when I people hear
this and say well Whitlock is because I
am I am for talking about Colin
Kaepernick got from a traditional sports
perspective and so Colin Kaepernick
kneels down and protests the flag and
police brutality and I'm like hey man
first of all this is bad business if you
are if you cut these kids young people
aren't even taught the business that
they've entered into sports
let's say you're a football player you
get to actually go study football in
college you would be understand like no
no the reason why you make so much money
is
Pete Rozelle or the television networks
decided to attach football to patriotism
and the military that's the way the game
is sold John with cinders voice all the
highlights have been packaged up all the
respect for the military and the flag
they wanted sports fans to feel like the
most American thing you can do besides
joining the military is sit on your ass
and watch football that's America that's
why Colin Kaepernick made 14 million
dollars because they were selling that
and it was give he just did some bad
business
what well I'm making money because the
people here believe they're supporting
America and they love it and it's
patriotism and I'm going to choose this
place to kneel down and protest America
and its brutality it's wrong
and it's over the police headquarters
and do that
I'm not against in protesting yeah do it
at police headquarters when you do it on
a football field where all the
television networks and the NFL are all
in on we're selling patriotism here it's
bad business is stupid so you're dealing
with it just a purely realist level yeah
so a former somewhat colleague of mine
did a video kind of bashing you about
this and it's like you're just dealing
with the you're just dealing with
reality the reality that if people stop
buying tickets if people stop buying
jerseys all of these things
well eventually you might get cut you
might not get the contract and not
everything takes place in between those
lines look when footballs the TV show
and so if James Gandolfini in The
Sopranos decided I'm a glob script I'm
going to become a religious figure on
this show I'm not going to be a mafia
Campea they would have fired him and got
someone else right because it's a TV
show
yeah this this is the role we want you
to play in the NFL this is how we make
money this is how we do our TV show he's
not playing his role and and all the
lunatic people that all my god what he
did was so courageous and this
none of them are going to put 14 million
dollars in Colin Kaepernick's pocket not
one of them yeah and even the ones that
might agree with him politically or yeah
with what he's fighting for
yes and so now here he is begging for it
to get back in MFL leaking out I won't
take any anymore he's having to back off
of the stands he took and again look how
preposterous it is I'm not gonna in the
protest go things improve for the better
Donald Trump elected president well
things have improved I'm nothing I'm not
gonna protest anymore so is it so it's
like sort of the perfect storm because
it's like you know you know it's the
idea of fighting against racism you're
fighting against capitalism you're
fighting is the patriarchy you're
fighting against all these sort of ideas
that they put out there yeah and at the
same kind of makes your victimhood thing
go off the chart so it's a perfect storm
it is and again people think I hate
Colin Kaepernick because I've been so
critical I'm just disappointed I
understand what he was trying to
accomplish Colin Kaepernick whether
people want to address it or not or deal
with they think I'm terrible for going
here but it's just factual he's got an
identity issue he's half black half
white both of his parents never knew his
dad his mom gave him up for adoption
he's raised by a suburban white family
and Milwaukee I don't care who you are
that's going to create some whoa in in
this America that's so racially divided
over social media that's going to create
some identity issues for you and Colin
Kaepernick's reputation before the
protest was horrible with his teammates
he was awkward didn't get along with
every people and then once he did this
thing now he's one of the blackest guys
in the history of America all everybody
across the league loves him and so he's
loving it I get it but it's bad business
for him he was been better off
continuing to create wealth who played
in the NFL and using that wealth to
effect real change for the people he
says he's concerned about
so maybe opening a school or an
after-school program or whatever it is a
lot of food Jalen Rose he's a former
athlete or NBA player huh it's got the
Jalen Rose Leadership Academy in Detroit
it's tremendous again many things LeBron
is doing in Akron tremendous that's
again when I the Muhammad Ali model is
done it's over it's not the 1960s
anymore there's too much money be made
and it's not the right role for athletes
the they're not political explosive the
Colin Kaepernick won't even come out and
talk anymore because there's not enough
substance for him to hold a press
conference and say anything everything's
all controlled or he's retweeting what
people were saying about him and trying
to speak for himself that way he's not
he's way out over his skis went to lay
out over skis it's so interesting
because it brings up so many things
about speech and capitalism and
democracy and the way we do is race and
all that stuff to circle back a little
bit though do you remember the moment
when you realized that the sports
business was being corrupted by this
leftist stuff because I can think of a
couple moments but I'll give you a
chance first before I tell you mine well
a lot of people will point to the
Caitlyn Jenner thing that's what I was
going to say and it that lonely that was
the end of it that was where I saw like
the full-on like because to give her the
SB again I'm I have trans friends I'm
totally you know for the trans community
I want them to be treated equally and
expect and all that stuff but he became
so obviously politicized that was it's a
fleet of the years all-time achievement
award or courage or images I over a
young woman that was dying a cancer to
continue to play basketball yeah it was
just like this is just silly more than
anything else that wasn't my moment I
because what I was and I wants because I
really have some respect for ESPN and
the people that run it but I'll just say
it because it's perfect I was inside the
belly of the beast you know and so I saw
it more acutely in terms of what I was
dealing with my second go-around and yes
Pierre
and and what I saw it again I'm not
demonizing anybody see a massive
corporation that is backed by Disney
another massive corporation right and
massive corporations in this era are a
lot like Congress there are a lot like
washing it's a lot like having something
in oil DC politics there are so many
special interest groups within a massive
corporation ESPN has something called
pulse people United to serve and lead in
excel it's it's their black employees
group they got something called pride
people respectful of individual
diversity excellence or sigh it's their
gay a special interest group they have a
couple other special interest groups and
uh again when you have special interest
groups
it makes decisions very compromises that
ESPN ISM a startup business that gets
ignored the virtually every rule and
just do what's right and we'll deal SPM
is an environment and most major
corporations are human resource
departments are all powerful
if you've gathered up some special
interest groups they have a lot of
powerful and it's hard to make the
absolute best decision in that
environment and so I saw that firsthand
how the special interest and the human
resources department had so much
influence over what took place that is
like oh this organization's handcuffed
it it can't just do the right thing for
its customer base they've got all these
agendas at work that put any leader in a
tough spot
yeah and ironically it's those agendas
as we've been talking about that it's
sort of led to the destruction of the
actual business yes which is a crazy
position so you're at Fox now and you
know I talked about the mainstream media
all the time and all that and I think
there's an idea out there that somehow
when you work at a big corporation that
they're telling you everything to say
and all that and I don't suspect they're
telling you to what to say at all but do
you find for yourself just to protect
you talk about your own rational
self-interest as a businessman and
someone that's putting your stuff out
there
do you and Colin ever sit down and
before you do a show and say well maybe
we shouldn't hit this in this way or
mate or maybe I'm going to go further
than you want to go this way or any of
that kind of stuff we have a lot of
discussions of Colin and I look race is
an area I've been operating in as a
media person for my entire career
it's what I'm passionate about I have a
lot more time to think about these
issues than most people it's my area of
expertise it's not Colin's area of
expertise uh and so we do talk about
that beforehand and you know had long
discussions about hey caller you know
I'm going to make sure I don't put you
in a bad place or some dangerous place
that gets fed some you gets you involved
in some kind of full-out rage situation
or whatever uh but we pretty much talk
about what we want to talk about and
Colin's pretty fearless uh and so it's
funny though I I hear all the time from
people all you're just saying what Fox
wants you to write right that's why I'm
Africa yeah and I was like hey I don't
think you understand the current media
culture and the pressures on executives
and people running networks now uh you
know if I'm an executive I'll speak
hypothetically I want to stay in very
safe places and so if I feel any
pressure that would be the pressure I
know I'm getting zero pressure to be an
outspoken person who goes against the
grain against what Twitter thinks is
popular about race no one is know if
anything I get the exact opposite yeah
preach to the choir but isn't at it so
they they're these very strong competing
forces then because if you want not if
you just want
of the clicks but if the clicks just
exist you say what you think right now
the clicks exist because you're saying
stuff that's outside of the mainstream
now you've got maybe executives that
just want to keep everything under
control
but at the same time they love that
conversation like they hate it in a way
because they don't want the heat to come
onto them or cause any problems for them
but so the heat works both ways here I
would say David though if you look at
where the clicks are the clicks aren't
in my perspective the question if you go
the way again you'll remember Silicon
Valley and San Francisco are controlling
the clicks and who gets clicks the
clicks are in the far left perspective
if you know if you really study who's
get it let's go back two years before
Fox News got involved in all the
controversy or whatever based on Twitter
and social media you would think that
Chris Hayes had a ten times bigger
audience than Bill O'Reilly
right up based on social media and so
the clicks are in you know saying that
the police are out here randomly killing
black people and America is completely
rigged against the black man you have no
chance that's where all the clicks are
yeah well that's it it's funny you
mention that because I think it's so
interesting now the foxes Fox News is
struggling that there's such a feeding
frenzy around it Fox was crushing
everybody but you're right
if you were to just look at retweets
obviously clearance is doing a lot
better than then Bill O'Reilly whose
account was more of like just a
corporate controlled account so you'd
think that their ratings would have been
much better but now there's such a
feeding frenzy because they see there's
blood in the water around Fox and
Friends reason well what anybody can
give ratings talk about Trump there are
and but you know I've often said and I
stand by this if you build any type of
media content based around pleasing
Twitter you're building something that's
going to fail that you're going to get
all kinds of clicks when we put real
people just start paying attention to
that
you know if I started saying this
the sharknado TV show woman I think they
might live up and all over Twitter and
then the radians came out and no one
lost and and I don't want to say this to
be disrespectful I'm not trying to start
anything but someone will see this a
nothing I'm just picking on but I wrote
a piece after Melissa harris-perry show
on MSNBC got cancelled and and I was
just like the show was completely built
for social media and it never rated no
one ever was and uh it's a mistake and
and I get we all our media so obsessed
with social media and we think that's
reality and I just keep trying to preach
people know man it's not remotely
reality it's not what America thinks if
you follow social media you thought
Trump was going to lose the election if
you believed in what you were seeing
social media yeah and it's just a false
indicator yeah all right so so one more
for you that I think post sort of ties
us all together at the top of the show I
mentioned and you know I talked about
free speech a lot and just in the last
week alone there was the Kathy Griffin
thing there was the Bill Maher thing I
don't know if you're following this
story about Brett Weinstein the
professor up at Evergreen State who got
in a lot of trouble over over not being
racist so they're of course they're
calling them raises point being there's
a lot of stuff around free speech then
you got into hot water about about
LeBron and the gate and all that what do
you think of just sort of the general
state of free speech because I tried to
explain to people these aren't First
Amendment issues this is none of these
things have anything to do with
government but but the chill factor that
you started talking about way back when
that this is real and not not everybody
is as brave as you where you you brush
this stuff off but which is the average
person how serious do you think this is
III think it's very serious I think that
I think it's as a media person I think
it's the biggest issue going again there
are clearly bigger issues of the climate
there's you know all kinds of issues
going on but for me as a media person
the silencing of original thought
the silencing of debate the fact that
people that disagree can't seem to find
a way to disagree respectfully and
exchange ideas that if you disagree with
someone they're evil and they must be
destroyed that's really troubling I mean
we're creating a society that will go to
a really dangerous place and get we keep
calling Trump the fascists and I don't
see the evidence of that I see those of
us in the media where the fascist who
everyone's trying to silence people and
trying to create a belief that someone
we disagree with is better off dead than
allowing them a platform yeah well I
love finding allies in this space and
it's very obvious to me that you're one
and we need more I mean that's what I
tell my elegance all the time we do I'm
just some guy to create a YouTube
channel you're some guy that is
passionate about sports and started
writing about it
and now people care and that's that's
what we need more of because we're just
two guys saying what we think you know
in the we need to I need to what I felt
and the why was attracted to your work
and what you're doing I gotta support
people that are real and regardless of
color regardless of religion regardless
of sexual orientation uh if you're real
I just got to support you uh because
it's just critically critically
important because the other side has all
gathered up because I believe a lot of
things are orchestrated I get you know
you've even missed the or we didn't talk
about you know I got attacked because I
defended someone that got in a argument
with Lavar ball the Lonzo balls dead and
and Charlamagne tha God who hosts a
popular urban hip-hop show in New York
made some Emmett Till analogy to
Kristine Leahy who I'm work with it so
how she's doing and so and then LeBron
James comes back two weeks later or
later talking about Emmett Till and I
don't have any proof but I'm just like
this feels orchestrated whoo-hoo
Kristine Leahy has a dispute with levar
ball and somehow it has something to do
with Emmitt to you and and Levon bronze
gate kids vandalized and somehow its
Emmett Till and so these talking points
are being passed around and it's
orchestrated to me I do agree and you
know I always quote Carl Sagan
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence so it's like you
don't have absolute to that but it's
always sort of like the fake news meme
the day after the election everybody
started talking about all the
mainstreamers saying everything is fake
news because they sort of lost control
of an area so I have no evidence that
there was a newsletter going around to
the heads of CNN and MSNBC but if you're
a thinking person you at least have to
explore that that situation to figure
out what we're up against I don't think
there's any question that there's an
orchestrated movement look I I felt like
what did spin from the Galka Network
they bullied the hell out of ESPN for
years and I think smart people by
ottoman the worldwide leader in sports
sports culture is conservative let's
let's go take on the head of the snake
ESPN and push them our direction and it
worked
I hit work yeah I believe that's been
pushed bullied ESPN into becoming
progressive yeah and I don't think it's
an accident because you know once their
job was done they started writing
celebratory pieces about how great ESPN
is yeah I suspect we're going to do this
again I hope so I think so
Remora Jason do you can watch him on
speak for yourself on Fox Sports one and
send all your hate tweets directly to a
weird life Jason but I'll ask you though
if I ask without you
[Music]
you